i had read you were leaving saturday
night live i 100 was leaving i like yeah
i 100 did i told them i was leaving
and the whole time lauren was like yeah
okay but like i 100 told them i was
leaving like at the beginning i was like
i'm done i can't do it i'm i'm finished
i'm finished i'm finished and no one
kind of believes it and then i said it
so longer and i told everybody so long
ago that i started kind of just saying
it like this is my last season and i set
it on stage and they picked it up
and i was still leaving when when i said
when i walked it back but i i walked it
back because i didn't want it to
distract from the season i didn't want i
hate when the show feels
like it's about my you know what i mean
yes so i was just like i don't want to
have to answer that question i don't
want my fellow cast members to have to
answer that question in interviews and
stuff like that so like it just it
doesn't just affect me so i was like
well if i'm going to leave i can
announce it when i'm actually gone but
you know it came down to why i wanted to
leave which was to have time to do other
things
and uh so you know i talked to lauren
and and we figured out something where
i'll i will have more time
and uh so you know it made it kind of
worth staying
yeah
you know it's weird too when you're in
the thick of it and saturday live is a
grind you're grinding out a lot of
comedy and writing for other people yeah
and also i think even financially you
could probably make more money on the
road doing comedy honestly saturday
night live is not infamously known for
paying people no it's not but my fantasy
is
to work the seller every day so like to
me you're not you don't really think
about the money you think more so about
that weapon of being on live television
appointment tellers like kind of the
last
place where you could where something
exciting can happen even if it doesn't
it's the possibility is there you know
it's nascar you know it's something
something crazy can happen
it's a championship fight so i think
that's still intoxicated i think that's
why people always come back but you know
after a while you just feel like i don't
even know if i have anything to offer
anymore you know you get a little bit
down on yourself and you just want to
kind of
do something different just to feel like
you're a stronger artist